hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the speed Chess
Championship 2022 it's nihal sarin
versus Anish giri and it's uh the exact
same format as we had in the match
Magnus Carlsen versus Gooker so first an
hour and a half of five plus one then an
hour of three plus one and then 30
minutes of bullet one plus one not real
bullet well one plus zero is much better
but I guess uh it would be considered
less serious if they didn't have this
increment as the the games are of a much
higher quality with this one second
increment uh some of you one second
might not be uh like you know a lot of
time but the the grand Masters like like
nihal and Anish it's uh like an eternity
uh so let's dive straight into it this
is a game from the five plus one section
really a nice attacking game and uh it
features a a great finish to the game uh
so nihal with the white pieces opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 by a niche
C for G6 Knight to C3 Pawn to D5 the
groomfield defense is on the board i2f3
with Bishop to G7 and now Pawn to E3 we
have castles and Bishop to D2 Bishop D2
is the main line Bishop to D2 is the
fourth most popular continuation so here
nihal already starting to to mix it up
with Fantasy 5 the characters on C5 and
now Knight to A6 going after the C5 Pawn
this way C captures on D5 Knight
captures on C5 and Bishop to C4 so
nothing new here this this has been
played many many times A6 we have Pawn
to a for stopping B5 and now Bishop to
F5
uh we have castles and Rook the C8 uh
this is uh it's not developing The
Rookwood tempo as uh okay the bishop and
CA C4 is unguarded uh but it's blocked
by the Knight on C5 so it's like a Tempo
x-raying move I thought this uh I don't
think this has a name in chess but I
thought it should have one so it's not
like a real Tempo move it's sort of an
x-ray Tempo move uh I don't know maybe
maybe uh so Queen to E2 defending the
bishop with Knight C to E4 uh offering
some traits here attacking the Knight on
C3 and the bishop we have Rook after D1
and now uh Knight the G4 I I will just
mention uh this uh position has happened
before and it even happened in a famous
game between Samuel rashevsky and uh
Paul benko from the 1969 us championship
and uh those of you who have been who've
seen my Bobby Fischer Saga uh know that
it's uh it's a pretty famous
Championship even though we haven't
covered it in The Saga we mentioned it
because Bobby Fischer didn't play in it
but as Paul benkok one third place I
think it was rashevsky won first place
Addison one second and the Paul Banker
won third place uh benko declined his
participation in the interzoneal
tournament of Palma de mayorca as this
was a zonal tournament you had to play
it before the interzone tournament and
then he gave his spot to Bobby Fischer
as Bobby Fischer could not play in the
palm of the America in Arizona
unless he qualified via the United
States Championship but Paul Bengal said
that it would be more fitting if Bobby
went he actually had a chance of winning
and he gave him his spot uh Bobby Wanda
the interzone he crushed everyone in in
the candidates tournament or basically
the candidates matches and then he went
on to defeat um uh Boris pasty so for
those of you who didn't know that also a
fun a fun fact without Paul benko and
his actual uh you know selflessness he
he just uh I don't know if it was true
selflessness or maybe he had other
reasons but I mean giving up a spot in
the candidates like this without it
Fisher would not be able to win in the
World Chess Championship but okay in
that in that game Bishop to G4 was
played by Bengal but here we have
Knights the G4 and it is now as of move
13 that we have a completely new game uh
so Knight captures an E4 we have Bishop
capture Sunny for and now Knight the G5
attacking the bishop here with Bishop to
F5 and pawn to e for nehal grabs at the
full Center Here and Now Anish doesn't
retreat with the bishop writer he plays
Queen to C7 attacks the bishop and C4
and also it could very uh it could be
easy to blunder the game here you might
play some Bishop to D3 and then Queen
captures than H2 yeah you have to be
careful not to do this queen to each one
would be Checkmate but of course the
nihal spots this he plays D6 he blocks
the queen and now just Queen captures on
C4 you could also play Queen captures on
D6 kinda trying to keep the tension but
then after
uh blocking checkmate with the G3 you
would be in a pretty pretty bad
situation as uh well your Bishop here is
still hanging and there's really no good
way to to deal with this if you move the
bishop back let's say Bishop to D7 then
Bishop to F4 attacks the queen and then
Bishop captures and F7 then The Rook
connects with with the bishop all sorts
of stuff is happening here uh it would
be a terrible mistake so instead after
D6 just Queen captures and C4 uh trading
pieces we have Queen captures and C for
Rook captures and now D captures an E7 a
beautiful past Pawn here Rook to E8 and
now e captures on F5 winning back the
piece with Bishop to D4 going after the
F2 pawn and now Bishop to C3 now
offering a trade of Bishops uh Bishop
captures an F2 with check and King to F1
King to H1 looks a bit scary but the
engine says that it's it's actually
perfectly fine but okay King to F1 this
is five minutes Blitz we have Bishop
actor B6 and now uh we are threatening
Knight characters on H2 but Bishop to B6
is a mistake and the F6 uh if uh on uh
nihal Sports this uh it's really hard to
play this with black and it's
unimaginable that black could get out of
this you can never win those spawns and
the The Rook is never entering the game
uh if the bishop ever moves from the
control of the d8 square then Rook the
d8 is coming so this is completely
winning for white but nihal misses it he
plays F captures on G6 with Rook death
for check now a niche uh has a much
better position King to E2 and now Rook
captures an E7 he eliminates this uh
Monster Pawn uh King to D3 getting out
of check and H captures on G6 with Rook
D1 offering a rook trade and now Rook
the D7 with check again now for Anish
Knights the E3 uh cutting off the king
from escaping with King to C2 uh would
be uh well close to winning it's winning
by force but not in a 5 min and Blitz
game so instead Rook the D7 Chuck was
played King to C2 and now Knights the E3
with check King B3 and now Pawn to F6
getting rid of this Knight and now not
moving the Knight but instead G3 and uh
although it's a fine move it attacks The
Rook so you have to move the rook and
then you know White's gonna figure out
what to do with the Knight the
implications of G3 are much much greater
than you can possibly imagine in this
moment but uh you know keep in mind this
G3 move for the rest of for the rest of
the game if you can do that
so Rook to F5 uh now allowing the the
fourth rank for the Knight with knights
the E4 and King to F7 adding more uh
defense to that F6 spawn as it was
attacked Rook to E2 and now Bishop to A7
uh we have Rook 8 to E1 doubling up on
the E file and now comes the move uh
that's uh well that's a bit of a bit of
a problem here uh Anish plays Knight to
G4 Knight to D5 or Rook to D3 were
basically the only moves that Anish can
play in order to not lose the game but
after Knight the G4 the game is now
completely winning for nihal but you
have to spot the correct idea so feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure out what Anish missed here uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
this spectacular Checkmate and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is night the D6 with check and yes
it's hard to imagine uh that uh this
variation ends in Checkmate but if you
had the G3 move in mind which I said
that you should then no doubt you found
Checkmate in this position and once
again congratulations on that the
problem is now if you just move the king
then The Rook hangs Knight captures on
F5 but you don't even have to do it
right away you can first give a check
force of trade of Rooks and then only
then even if King f8 Knight captures an
F5 defense The Rook so you're gonna
first have to capture the Knight and
then we'll capture some B7 and you're up
upon your up the exchange you have a
rook for a night completely winning for
white so instead after Knight to D6
check and he said all right I have to go
for it a rook captures on D6 Rook to E7
with Trek it's now actually a mate in
five uh King the G8 rooked the E8 with
check came to G7 Rook won the E7 with
check only move King to H6 and now Rook
the h8 with check forcing the king to G5
and now you see why I asked you to keep
that G3 move in mind it allows a very
nice Pawn to H4 check without allowing
the black king to escape to F4 and it is
now on move 38 that Anish giri got
checkmated so what a what a spectacular
King [ __ ] even without the Queens on the
board finding uh a way to sacrifice more
material for this beautiful trackmate we
can we can see the line one more time
just you know giving up the night
winning the seven square for The Rook
rookie 7 check rookie check rookie seven
check Rook to h8 check and now H for
checkmate absolutely absolutely stunning
uh so a lot of you guys have requested
this one so I hope you guys enjoyed it
it's uh I I enjoyed it immensely when I
saw it so I thought you guys might as
well and this one was not as clean as uh
uh the the the match between Magnus and
Lucas should have ended the 2020 23 7.
uh this one uh was decided by one point
uh out of the 29 games uh I believe the
the result was uh 15 to 14 in a neha's
favor and uh it everything got decided
in uh in bullet so it was an incredible
match and uh anyone could have won but
in the end the nehal won and he will be
facing dingler and in the uh semi-finals
of the speed Chess Championship uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that a little bit of uh
uh trip down memory lane uh regarding
Paul benko and him giving up his spot to
Bobby Fischer to play in the
I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Umar Jamal and I would like
to thank Benjamin hallberger uh
ravishing reptiles YouTube home and
anubhav katiel for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day